this is memorial day weekend it's
expected to be the busiest
travel period that we've seen here in
the u.s in 15 months as we
get out of the pandemic hector mejia
live this morning with a look at what we
can expect here in las vegas this
weekend hector good morning to you
good morning john we can expect a lot of
people these past few weekends we've
seen crowds steadily increase here along
the las vegas strip and the welcome sign
and
that's just going to look like a slight
warm up compared to what's coming ahead
this weekend
some 37 million people are expected to
travel this weekend for memorial day
most by car that's a massive increase
from this time last year though still
down from 2019 aaa says las vegas will
be among the hottest travel destinations
in the entire country
this weekend when it comes to memorial
day las vegas actually ranks the second
most popular
right behind orlando florida and right
below that
number three is honolulu hawaii so it's
going to be a strong
weekend for las vegas we're expecting a
lot of people to come
and enjoy what las vegas has to offer
we have a lot to offer sergio avila with
aaa says it's important to do some
research before you go anywhere and
catch up on any changes
to services or local coveted rules
memorial day monday is also the last day
of most restrictions here in the county
which means we can expect big crowds and
booming business all summer long and if
you plan to hit the road
like some people are right now this
morning now might be the best time
aaa says the most traffic is expected in
the afternoon between 3 pm
and 6 pm reporting live this morning
hector mejia 8 news now